some films are a must-see because of the
part they play in our collective
cultural conversation watching them
unlock the world of references hub
trivia answers metaphors and dinner
party icebreakers but other films are
required viewing because of what they
can teach us about love hope despair
faith family and even warm and fuzzy
alert ourselves here are just a few of
the movies you need to see before you
die before sunrise regardless of your
own romantic track record it behooves
you to catch Richard Linklater's 1995
romantic drama before sunrise before you
kick the bucket it's perhaps the most
accurate depiction of two young people
falling in love and cinematic history
and since it takes place and as close to
real time as most people would be
willing to bear it affords you the
privilege of being swept up into the
order in beautiful Vienna Austria no
less it's like you're to fly on the wall
of a room - and possibly charming people
have built out of pure conversation on
the first day of a decades-long
relationship
dear Zachary the 2008 documentary dear
Zachary is one of the Roth's most
heart-wrenching depictions of what it
means to be a family ever committed to
film it's an emotionally devastating
love letter that also requires you to
think critically about the meaning of
justice friendship and parenting just
one thing make sure you watch it with
someone who has already seen you ugly
cry because tears are almost guaranteed
Groundhog Day
Harald Ramos is 1993 comedy fantasy
Groundhog Day is mandatory viewing not
only because it's widely considered a
comedy masterpiece but also because it's
been adopted and rightfully so as a sort
of Zen guide to self-improvement
or the fact that Bill Murray's spiritual
makeover is thoroughly nondenominational
makes the film and its message all the
more universal the change comes from
within and it's ultimately motivated not
by a desire to escape his time prison
but instead to improve himself and
improve the lives of those around it and
it's funny to boot how could you go
wrong spotlight in the same family as
all the president's men spotlight shows
the power of investigative journalism
and how a free press can take down the
powerful spotlighted to film for you the
film which won the Oscar for Best
Picture in 2016 is a tense dramatic
thriller even though almost all of the
action involves people talking debating
discussing and thinking about what the
ultimate meaning and importance of truth
is we got to nail these scumbags we got
to show people that nobody could get
away with it not a priest or carnal
freaking Pope not always an easy film to
watch but when you've done chances are
you'll want to watch it again and again
Oh Jay made in America dedicating almost
eight hours of your life to a 2016
documentary series about the OJ Simpson
trial may sound like a lot to ask
especially to those who already sat
through a lifetime of media coverage
about the trial back in 1995 but OJ made
in America is less about the trial
itself and more about celebrity misogyny
Los Angeles identity justice race yes
the American Dream including why not
dream is off limits the large parts of
the population it's essential not just
to understanding the OJ trial but to
understanding our nation as well
election Alexander Payne's 1999 comedy
election is an almost perfect film about
high school politics class and
infidelity set in Nebraska the film
captures the dreary Midwestern sadness
and takes the stereotypical characters
the jock they're trying to leave the
closeted lesbian the overachiever and
masterfully humanized them and of course
there's Reese Witherspoon's masterful
performances the deceitful Tracy Flick I
don't know what you're referring to that
maybe have certain older wiser people
hadn't acted like such little babies and
gotten so mushy then everything would be
okay
of course almost everyone in the film is
also a pretty awful person but hey
this is high school after all going
clear Scientology and the prison of
belief if you've ever wondered what the
big deal about Scientology is 2015's
going clear Scientology and the prison
of belief is exactly the documentary for
you but even if you don't think you're
interested in Scientology the film is a
fascinating discourse on blind faith
manipulation willingness the crowds to
follow charismatic leaders despite all
logic and reason and that's a message
for everyone no matter what your
religion citizen came no doubt some of
you have avoided watching 1941 Citizen
Kane simply because everyone keeps
telling you to see it but there's a
reason the Orson Welles classic is
considered by many film fans and
historians to be the most important most
influential and straight up best film of
all time not only did it innovate all
sorts of filmmaking techniques that are
still in use today it did it in service
to a dazzlingly well told the early
contemporary story about a rich
businessman who uses his money personal
charisma and influence over the media to
become a powerful politician I made no
campaign promises because until a few
weeks ago I had no hope being elected
some story some movie are simply
timeless thanks for watching click the
grunge icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love do
[Music]
[Applause]